翻訳: Wataru Oda
校正: Yuri Ueda
みなさん こんにちは
（こんにちは）
私は夢を描き 夢を形にする
遊園地のアトラクションデザイナーでした
いつも楽しいことばかりを考えていたお陰で
柔らかい頭と遊び心を失わずに
大きく羽ばたくことができました
そんな形ですので
独自のこんなサラリーマンに
なってしまいました
まぁ普通は スーツなんかを
着ていると思いますが
今日見ていただいたら わかりますように
こんなラフな格好で 今やっております
私が遊園地企画の中で最も大切にしていたのは
この２つのソウゾウリョクです
こんなアトラクションがあったら
子ども達は喜ぶだろうなって構想を練る
イマジネーションの想像力
それを形にしていく クリエーションの創造力
この２つのソウゾウリョクは
０から100に作り上げるまで
非常に大切なプロセスでした
ところが いつも楽しいアイデアが出るのが
50歳ぐらいの私たち
若いエンジニアからは
あまり楽しいアイデアが出てきませんでした
形にするときも同様でした
同僚は自分の考えたものを
即実行に移していたのですけれども
若手は知識だけに頼り 手が動きませんでした
どうしてかなって 考えていたときに
やはり 原体験の引き出しが
少ないのではないのかな
という風に考えました
私 今57歳ですけれども
すごくワクワクすることが
頭に浮かんでくるのですけれども
どうして若い子は 出てこないのだろうな
そういうのを考えている中で
私は子どもの研究に 従事したことがあります
その時 なぜ今の子達が
考える力が少なくなったか
そういうことも
分析していったのですけれども
どうも 知識ばかりを
詰め込むのではなくって
能動体験をすることによって
考える力を育む
これがすごく重要じゃないかな という風に
気づくようになりました
そこで２つのソウゾウリョクを高めるための
環境づくりを私はやっていきたい という風に
夢を持つようになりました
すると ワクワクが止まらなくなり
定年を待たずに早期退職
三重県桑名市にある廃校を再利用し
「子どもアイデア楽工」を設立しました
遊びながら学ぶ
能動体験型学習を通して
今の子ども達の個性や能力を
引き出すようにしています
では今日は この２つのソウゾウリョクを
私の作品と子どもの作品で
比較して見たいと思います
私の作品 こちらがですね
バードカーヴィングと言いまして
木彫の鳥の彫刻です
見ていただいたらわかるように
ちょっとまわして頂いてもよいですか
角材を掘り出して
鳥を仕上げていって
最後に彩色するのですけれども
非常に緻密な作業が行われます
ただ こちらの作品のように
見ていただいたらわかるように
主役の鳥がメインに
光り輝いていますよね
それを違う方向で考えてみたいな という
遊園地企画屋の血が流れました
そこで 考えだしたのが
これアケビコノハという 昆虫ですけれども
見ての通りですね
葉っぱそっくりですよね
これを枯葉の中に入れてみました
さあ皆さん どこに
アケビコノハがいるでしょうか
わかる人
わからないですよね
正解はこちらにいます
これだ！ とひらめいちゃったのですね
鳥を消し去ろう！
奇想天外な逆転の発想で
鳥を消そうという
とんでもない発想が生まれました
それをどうやったら消せるかを
考えたときに
このヨタカという鳥が 卵を抱くときに
まさに擬態化する ということを知りました
その鳥を消すために
私は非常に悩みました
どうやったら消えるのだろう
ここからが大変です
今までは楽しいことを
考えている時間だったのです
これを実際に鳥を消すための
実作業に移していかなければいけません
形にするために
銅板の葉っぱ1300枚
これはここに今 隠れていますけれども
鳥を消し去るために
1300枚 銅板で作りました
一枚あたり １時間はかかります
ということは1300時間
かかっていることになります
サラリーマンをやりながら
制作をしていたものですから
大体 夜の２時間ぐらいです
つまり 650日間 製作にかかりました
650日間っていうのは 二年越しの作品です
ちょっと皆さん
見ていただいていいですか
鳥が 消えていたら 拍手してくださいね
行きます
じゃじゃん　わかりますか
鳥がいるの
あれ　あまり反応がなくないですかね
(拍手)
ここにヨタカがいます
こんな形で夢を描くときはワクワク
夢を形にするのはコツコツです
では 私が「子どもアイデア楽工」で子どもと
どういう風に接しているか というのを
お話しさせていただきたいと思います
今度は 子どもの作品です
私は２つのソウゾウリョクを引き出すために
いろいろな呪文をかけていきます
例えばこれ
この作品はあるコンテストで
優秀賞を取った作品です
これも（会場の）玄関に置いて
あったのですけれども
この作品を はじめ構想するとき
イマジネーションの構想のときは
テーマが「未来にあったらいいな」
というのがテーマです
もちろん未来っていうのは
漠然としすぎているものですから
私は テーマを絞って
子ども達に接していきます
例えば 未来にどんな
ロボットがあれば 便利かな とか
未来のどんなお家に 住みたいかな
こういう風にして絞っていきます
その時に 私は「呪文」という言葉を
使わしていただきましたけれども
こんな感じで いつもお話をしています
例えば 些細なちっちゃい
アイデアが出てきたとき
そのときに 私は
「すっごい！すごいなー！」
って声をかけます
あと しらけないでくださいね
(笑)
「すごいなー！」って声をかけると
子どもはいい気になって
結構ちょっとお鼻が天狗になるのですね
そのときに夢を 今度は膨らませる呪文
「それで それで！」
もうこれだけです
「それで それで！」って声をかけます
そうすると アイデアが出てきます
そうなると すごく
私にとっては しめしめです
ただ当然 その行き着くところが
止まっちゃう時があります
その時は 視点を変える呪文
「他には？」
って聞いてあげます
そういう質問をすることによって
頭を切り替えます
そして 新たに出てきたものに対して
認める呪文
「なるほど！」
こういう形でやっています
ちょっとこれを 子どもとの会話で
やってみたいと思うのですけれども
「ねえねえ 未来にどんな
乗り物があったら 楽しいかな」
「えーっとー 宇宙船のような乗り物の中に
遊園地があるビークル！」
「いいね それ！
それで それで！」
「えっとー 秘密基地のような
遊園地を作りたい」
「すごい！それどうなっているの？」
「ええっとね 間伐材で
楽しい アトラクションを作りたい！」
「すごい すごいぞ！その他に それでは？」
「えっとねー うーんとねー」
「他には？」
「えっ 他には？
他には 図書館がある」
「えっ なるほど！
わからないことがあったら 調べるわけだ
素晴らしい それで それで」
「えっと 世界中の子ども達が集まっている」
「えーすごい！それで それで！」
「うんとー 子ども達は うんとー
ホテルのような 住居スペースに住んでいる」
「いいな それ その他には？」
「んー 展望露天風呂もある」
こんな感じで考えてくれたのが これです
見ていただいたらわかるように
巨大な宇宙船の中に
遊園地が入っています
ですから 今 お話をさせていただいたように
こういうイマジネーションを
引き出すときには
私はミスを見つけて 指摘するのではなくて
ポジティブな発想で声をかけています
そうすることによってどんどんと
子どもの発想力 想像力が膨らんでいきます
それを今度はイメージを
形にしなければいけません
これがまた先ほどの
これと一緒で大変なのですね
知識とかスキルがない子どもに
どうやって形にしていくか
私はその時に考えさせる呪文
どのようにすればできるか を伝えていきます
なぜできないか じゃなくって
どうすれば Howで聞くわけですね
そのHowで聞くことによって
頭がフル回転します
その時に 私はヒントや選択肢を
与えるようにお話をしています
例えば 「このボディどういう風に作るの？」
「うんとねー
格好いい流線型のボディにしたいんだ」
「それ どのようにすればできるの？」
「えー わかんない」
「わかんないよね
じゃあさ ここで作った中で
流線型のものって作ったことない？」
「あっ あった ピニャータだ」
ピニャータというのは
南米のお誕生日会などで使われる
くす玉のようなものなのですけれども
そういうやり方でやれば
できるんじゃないか ということで
新聞紙とかクッキングペーパーを使い
さらに色紙を使って
このように作っていきました
さらにプロペラは ペットボトルリサイクル
観覧車は藤のつるでできた 自然素材クラフト
その他 全て廃材を活用して作っていきました
どうでしょう すごく私が大好きなのは
この子どもの真剣な真顔の表情です
頑張ってコツコツ仕上げて
出来上がりました
ただ先程言ったように優秀賞だったのです
最優秀賞ではなかったのです
すごく悔しがっていました
だから いま今年も
チャレンジしてくれています
この２つのソウゾウリョクを育むことによって
子どもは大きく成長していくと考えます
その時に イマジネーション
ワクワクしながら
楽しいことを考えることによって
物事への興味が湧きいでます
その時に探究心 あるいは好奇心が
湧き出てきます
想像力 イマジネーションではなくて
クリエーションの創造力の時は
あきらめずにコツコツ作ることによって
不屈な精神力が培われていくと思います
さらに チャレンジすることによって
うれしい！ くやしい！かなしい！たのしい！
こういった感情が湧き出ることによって
闘争心や冒険心に つながって行くと思います
最後に
「子どもアイデア楽工」に来ないと
２つのソウゾウリョクが鍛えられない
とんでもないです
各ご家庭 あるいは職場で
「すごい ！」 「それで 」
「 他には？」 「 なるほど！」
そして 「どうやったらできるか？」
そういう風なポジティブな声かけによって
考える力は鍛えられていくと思います
皆さんも一緒に ２つのソウゾウリョクを
鍛えていこうじゃありませんか
今日はどうもありがとうございました
(拍手)